abused extras drunk stars and way too
many cooks in the kitchen this is a wild
true story of the making of 1993's Super
Mario Brothers if you're watching a
movie made by a major Hollywood studio
there's a good chance it was either
partially or completely Rewritten
multiple times by multiple writers but
even considering that standard Super
Mario Brothers had a lot of writers to
be specific about a dozen scribes turned
in drafts the number of writing teams
hired and then in ceremonious he fired
early scripts were more reminiscent of
the games as they were colorful and
featured many of the villains and allies
that Mario encountered throughout his
side-scrolling adventures also Cooper
was actually a giant spider lizard but
when producers finally settled on a pair
of directors they brought along their
own ideas for script revisions the
directing team of Rocky Morton and
Annabelle jankel were best known as
their creators of the dystopian sci-fi
character Max Headroom their ideas were
the ones that mostly ended up on the
Final Cut of the movie but the producers
were so worried that Morton and jungle
had so radically departed from The
Source material that a new set of
writers were brought in to fix it the
producers then barred the directors from
even speaking to the new writers when
the principal cast arrived on set and
read the new version of the script for
the first time they were Furious and
this pretty much set the tone for the
entire production to come there's no
denying that Bob Hoskins was an ideal
physical fit to play Mario but the role
could have gone to a few different
actors all of whom are legends and their
own right two time Oscar winner Dustin
Hoffman wanted the pass but Nintendo
didn't feel that he was the best fit so
producers turned their sights towards
Danny DeVito though he'd turned them
down then the casting process turned
towards one of the biggest names in
Hollywood history Tom Hanks at the time
Hanks was a rising star who was Charming
in every film lucky enough to cast him
the lust though his two most recent
films at the time The Burbs and the
bonfire of the vanities flopped at the
box office and scared off producers in
the years to come Hanks would win two
Academy Awards and basically become
America's dad so things ultimately
probably worked out for the best for him
Birds who knows what alternate universe
would be living in if Hanks was Mario
and Bob Hoskins as Forrest Gump you
never know what you're going to get
instead of taking inspiration from the
actual Super Mario video games the
screenwriters look towards big budget
adult-oriented violence action movies in
particular they drew from the likes of
Die Hard Mad Max And Blade Runner in the
late 80s and early 90s those three films
were the cultural touchstones that
pretty much everyone was referencing
when it came to Blockbusters sci-fi and
action the die-hard inspiration was so
extreme that one version of the script
even called for a Bruce Willis Cameo the
idea was for him to be crawling to the
air vents above Cooper's office another
version of the screenplay took direct
inspiration from the Mad Max franchise
by having the characters driving tricked
out post-apocalyptic cars and
participating in Death Races but all
this in mind it sounds like nobody in
charge of making the Super Mario
Brothers movie I actually wanted to make
a Super Mario Brothers movie before
Super Mario Brothers directors Morton
and Janko had worked primarily on music
videos and had some experience making a
couple of dark and trippy features so
when it came to the visual aspect of
making a movie they were legitimately
Innovative for their time but their
philosophies might have been a little
too wild for Nintendo case in points
they didn't even want to dress Mario and
Luigi in their classic overalls this was
a major point of contention with the
producers demanding that Mario and Luigi
look at least a little bit like they did
in the video games Morton and Janko
fought them tooth and nail for most of
the production until they finally gave
in so if not for the producers dogged
insistence the only visually
recognizable aspect of Mario and Luigi
likely would have just been Bob Hoskins
mustache
Morton and jankal's arrogance
effectively ruined their film careers
and any chance of making a single friend
on the Mario set the cast and crew
pretty much hated the directing Duo
often resorting to calling them names
behind their backs and grumbling about
their bizarre Antics Bob Hoskins
believed that Morton and jungle had no
idea what they were doing while Dennis
Hopper complained that they weren't very
good at communicating script changes at
one point Morton was looking over the
extras he thought one of them didn't
look dirty enough so he grabbed a cup of
coffee and allegedly poured it over the
extras head Morton claimed that the
coffee had been sitting around for a
while though he also said that when the
extra complained that it was hot he Dows
the extra with cool water to soothe the
pain then when it came time for reshoots
The Producers didn't allow the directing
Duo to shoot even a single new frame
their slow disassociation from the film
reached its peak when they were also
banned from the editing room John
Leguizamo and Bob Hoskins became so
disgruntled during production that they
eventually started drinking Scotch to
pass the time and make the dark days go
by a little easier berta's luck would
have it on one of the days they were
kicking back shots they were called on
to set to shoot a scene in which they
had to drive the Mario Brothers Plumbing
van Leguizamo was then reportedly a
little shaky behind the wheel when the
director's yelled action he slammed the
accelerator and then he quickly slammed
on the brake the van sliding door
slammed shut on her Skin's right hand
and then he had to wear a flesh-toned
cast and that clearly wasn't hoskin's
only bad memory from the whole
production in August 2007 he opened up
about the whole experience during an
interview with the guardian to say that
he didn't hold back would be putting it
mildly as he recalled the worst thing I
ever did was Super Mario Brothers it was
a nightmare the whole experience was a
nightmare it had a husband and wife team
directing whose arrogance had been
mistaken for talent nightmare idiots
when bringing the Super Mario World to
life the filmmakers made the unique
choice to not include Princess Peach but
instead Princess Daisy she's played by
Samantha Mathis who was perhaps then
best known for the 1990 cult classic
Pump Up the Volume however those with
Keen ears May recognize mathis's voice
from another movie at least just a year
before Super Mario Brothers that would
be fun Gully the last rainforest in
which he plays Krista the young fairy
who stands up to toxic sludge monster
hexes and falls in love with Zach The
Lumberjack
plus your eyes with magic light I give
the gift a fair size
it's pretty impressive for someone to
play two different iconic characters
within a year of each other even if the
daisy of the video games are a little
different than the version math has
played even if you find Super Mario
Brothers Charming despite its flaws you
probably wouldn't mention the word
Oscars in the same breath as this movie
nevertheless there was actually a viable
candidate for a coveted statuette as it
was among the films under consideration
for a nomination for best visual effects
at the 66th Academy Awards ultimately
however the competition was too much for
Super Mario Brothers to snag a
nomination especially considering the
other big dinosaur-themed movie of that
year Jurassic Park still Mario is in
good company as other Fantastical
favorites from that year like Hocus
Pocus and Adam's Family Values didn't
make the cut either despite also being
under consideration a nomination would
have been well deserved though as Super
Mario Brothers actually pioneered some
significant new visual effects
technology and software even though
script rewrites were basically a daily
occurrence on the Super Mario Brothers
set the actors genuinely tended to stick
with the lines they were given once they
were finalized even Dennis Hopper who
reportedly once spent more than three
hours chastising the directors over the
constant dialogue changes eventually
chose to go along with what was written
but Richard Edson who plays King
Cooper's henchman spike is one actor who
essentially threw the script out the
window also going off script was Fischer
Stevens who played Spike's henchman
partner in crime Iggy as edsem revealed
in a 2011 interview his and Stevens the
satisfaction with the original dialogue
led to them pitching new material to
jangle and Morton the directors were
impressed enough to give them almost
complete control over their characters
including a rap that sadly ended up on
The Cutting Room floor
I missed nice job
one of the most iconic heroic characters
from the Super Mario franchise is a
humanoid Toadstool Toad but alas he
doesn't have a very big role in the
Super Mario Brothers movie he's played
by Mojo Nixon as a musician who provides
useful exposition to Mario and Luigi
before being turned into a Goomba by
king cooper he does appear a few more
times after that but it's not a very
significant part that wasn't always
going to be the case though in multiple
versions of the script toad is a key
Ally when's Mario and Luigi end up in
King Cooper's world in the first
screenplay draft he was originally going
to look like a three foot tall
toadstool-shaped creature basically his
appearance in the video games rather
than a human with a funky haircut a
later draft we invented towed as being
part humanoid and part chameleon which
subsequent writers initially stuck with
before downplaying his lizard features
in a later revision if you ask anyone
who worked on Super Mario Brothers
they'll probably tell you it was a
pretty rough experience and their
opinion of the final product generally
isn't so great either Samantha Mathis
for one called it a pretty bad movie
when she stopped by the Saturday morning
rewind podcast in 2019 but that isn't to
say that they completely hate it Mathis
also noted that she does appreciate the
affection from the fans who love the
movie and as John Leguizamo told slash
film in 2022 he's gained a greater
affection for the flick for the same
reason he also appreciated the
trailblazing decision to cast a
Colombian actor like himself in a
leading role and Fisher Stevens even
told Entertainment Weekly in 2021 I
can't wait till my kids are old enough
to watch this movie and visual effects
designer and supervisor Chris Woods has
praised the work that he and his
colleagues did for the film meanwhile
Alan oppone of the production company
makeup and effects laboratory said in a
2011 interview we achieved everything
and more than we set out to do
Super Mario Brothers wraps up most of
its plot points fairly conclusively but
just before the credits start to roll
viewers are hit with a Whopper of a
tease when Daisy shows up at the Mario
Brothers apartment in full-on combat
gear to recruit the siblings for another
adventure so you could easily be
forgiven for thinking that there's a
Super Mario Brothers sequel out there
and you'd actually be kind of rice this
sort of Super Mario Bros 2 exists as a
digital fun comic created by Ryan Haas
and Stephen Applebaum the owners of the
Super Mario Brothers the movie archive
website in addition to Daisy and the
brothers characters like Daisy's father
King Reznor appear in expanded roles the
comic also expands upon the powers that
Daisy gets from her Dimension bridging
meteor fragment what sets the comic
apart from other fan continuations that
it has input from Parker Bennett who
penned the film's second draft though
the original comic remains unfinished a
reworked version debuted in 2021 that
seemingly swaps Wars out with Dino
Hatton police chief Sergeant Simon one
of King Cooper's former Associates thank
you
[Music]